connaissez-vous la génération alpha bâ
ce sont les jeunes b depuis 2010 ils
sont déjà confrontées aux écrans depuis
leur naissance à oran de le dire parfois
sembler menés quasiment avec le
cellulaire à la main alors face au
risque que représente cette
surexposition aux écrans l'association
des psychiatres du québec avec d'autres
associations notamment des pédiatres des
travailleurs sociaux lance un mouvement
de réflexion du même nom el fath
connecter pour tenter de sensibiliser la
population les familles en tout cas et
les pouvoirs publics à cette question
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure avec la
présidente de l'association et
instigatrice du mouvement karine et
garde soit de l'association des pics à
docteur regarde toi bonsoir bienvenue à
24,60 merci de me recevoir
à lire les données vous avez rendu
public aujourd'hui entendre le cri
d'alarmé que vous lancez concernant les
jeunes concernant la génération alpha
dont on sait très peu de champ à très
peu de choses alors dites-nous sait qui
c'est qui cette génération la génération
elle fois c'est ceux qui sont nés en
même temps que l'ipad donc à partir de
2010 c'est la génération qui n'aura
jamais connu de vie sain le wise as an
les cellulaires sans l'internet sans
gougaud c'est la génération qui est née
avec la technologie dans l'est mais
c'est la génération qui est la plus
éduquée mais aussi qu'il a plu sur
stimuler savez la technologie elle est
arrivée son mode d'emploi et je pense
qu'il va falloir équiper nos jeunes avec
un mode d'emploi qui est plus dans les
générations éduquées assez riche mais
très très très anxieuse déjà on peut
constater que je suis chez les enfants
il ya des problèmes et où ça s'est un
peu plus tard que ça se manifeste
mais selon l'institut de la statistique
du québec un jeune sur trois se déclare
comme étant en détresse psychologique ce
qu'on sait c'est que dans les six
dernières années les troubles anxieux
ont doublé la prise de médicaments que
ce soit des antidépresseurs des
antipsychotiques des psychostimulants
tous ces médicaments l'offre a augmenté
les mêmes les hospitalisations pour des
tentatives de suicide chili 10 à 19 ans
augmentent et où ils disent
donc oui on est entrés tous les tous les
signes qu'on a tout les chiffres qu'on
ne nous montre qu'il ya une détresse qui
s'accélère chez notre jeunesse et c'est
pour ça qu'on a lancé ce mouvement là
parce que on le sait la santé mentale
c'est le parent pauvre de la santé c'est
sous financé on est à 6 % alors qu'ils
ont deux pays est à peu près 12 et que
le fardeau de la maladie mentale est
plutôt de l'ordre de 20% n'ont consisté
qu'on est sous financé mais même si on
était financé à l'ordre de 20%
avec l'accélération de la détresse si on
fait pas quelque chose pour renverser la
vapeur on n'arrivera jamais parce que
déjà donc je les enfants qui sont
branchés connecter des nourrissons
quasiment dwyer men et granville
vous craignez que déjà ça laisse une
empreinte extrêmement négative anxiogène
en fait c'est l'enfant en fait on ne
peut pas encore équipé notre jeunesse à
être capable de composer avec cette vie
numérique
donc il ya plusieurs choses que les
problèmes et les écrans d'une part il ya
des effets directs et indirects des
écrans l'effet direct c'est que on se
compare constamment on est constamment
connecté et on n'a pas le temps de
prendre du recul
donc si je me chicaner que je continue
ma she can en numérique
j'ai pas le temps de décanter j'ai pas
le temps de réfléchir j'ai pas le temps
de prendre du recul qui doit finalement
c'était pas si pire que ça
donc de ce côté là il ya le côté de la
cyber intimidation aussi le côté de la
comparaison constante avec la version
photoshop et de la vie des autres
donc il ya tous ces effets directs des
écrans il ya aussi l'effet indirect qui
est plus on passe de temps sur les
écrans - on pense autant jouer dehors à
faire du sport est en face à face à la
réélection à se parler de vive voix et à
dormir aussi on sait que les ados manque
énormément de sommeil et campsas mais
sur les réseaux sociaux au milieu de la
nuit il y en a un qui doit pas y arriver
et l'autre c'est tous des comportements
qui nuisent à la santé mentale et qui
sont augmentés par l'utilisation mais il
faut poser des solutions parmi ces
solutions il y aurait
d'enseigner la santé mentale dès le
primaire oui comment vous imaginez ce
coureur cette question d'expliquer aux
enfants aux primaires ce qu'on vise
c'est vraiment l'éducation sociale et
motive donc c'est d'apprendre à nommer
ses émotions et d'apprendre à s'apaiser
soi même c'est d'apprendre ensuite à
être capable d'un temps patick envers
les autres de reconnaître les émotions
chez les autres c'est ensuite la
capacité de résoudre les conflits de
façon pacifique non violente donc donc
ça parle d vraiment de sens du
relationnel qu'on veut faire au primaire
au secondaire l'on n'est plus dans la
gestion de sa vie numérique la gestion
de l'hygiène de vie
on n'est plus aussi dans la connaissance
des risques par rapport aux maladies
mentales et la gestion du risque ce soit
pour les drogues le tabac les médias
sociaux parce qu'on pensait qu'avec un
service de garde très développée
peut-être même les maternelles qu'on
allait apprendre aux enfants à bien
socialiser et en même temps ce qu'on
nous dit ce qu'on appelle régulièrement
à travers les médias ça quel point
l'école est un lieu d' intimidation est
un lieu où toutes les inégalités tous
les rapports de force se joue est ce que
vous vous êtes offensée que les enfants
sont pas préparés à sa victime
et vous savez quand c'est rendu que se
parler de vive voix
c'est un indications d'intimité ça veut
dire que je mets rapport au quotidien
sont par des textos qui parle emerging
puis que quand j'arrive pour parler de
vie voir quelqu'un parce que c'est un
team
là on a un problème légal et les jeunes
sont plus capables de regarder les gens
dans les yeux sa vie le souper de
famille où chacun doit attendre son sont
aux pourparlers puissent intéresser à
l'hôpital on apprend à travers ses
soupers de famille et ils les familles
sont tellement sous pression que des
grands problèmes évidemment maintenant
les familles des souris qui se déroule
avec les cellulaires sur la terre
passionnant et en même temps l'accès aux
ressources qu'on appelle que vous fait
d'avoir plus de ressources également
l'accès aux ressources psychologiques
c'est encore extrêmement difficile
son voeu de l'aigle s'est passé et c'est
long il
on est sous financé la santé mentale et
sous-financée c'est clair mais ce qu'on
lance avec ce mouvement si c'est dire au
delà du fait que oui il faut rehausser
le financement santé mentale au delà du
fait qu'il faut revoir l'accès qu'il
faut qu'ils aient plus de psychologues
de travailleurs sociaux
d'ergothérapeutes dans le réseau au delà
de ça si on s'attaque pas aux causes de
détresse des jeunes on n'arrivera jamais
il ne se pose là pour vous sur les
écrans entre autres ou et oui merci le
coup d'envoi reykjavik 9 à suivre
peut-être les actions de votre mouvement
oui mais on espère que c'est un dialogue
de société qui va durer dans le temps
l'idée sepsis et d'amorcer une réflexion
tout le monde enfants il ya ce que le
gouvernement peut faire meilleur ce que
chaque famille peut faire aussi
c'est simplement de dire ok on soupe ce
soir nos cellulaires ça serait déjà un
début
parce que facile d'enlever tablait pour
un cellulaire en juin winnie un adulte à
von ah oui aussi accro que et ils
apprennent de nous sans doute c'est
simple on est leur modèle et quand je
dis on n'a pas eu de mode d'emploi sur
comment utiliser les technologies pour
les hôtes est un peu malade différent du
que des trottoirs pour faire attention
parce que quelqu'un pour nous foncer
dessus sans traverser la rue oui
bonne chance regarde toi merci d'un coup